[Music]
it's not easy to find the sun in lordran
and when you do see it who's to say it's
real
the age of fire is ending and the world
is already dark
logan believes that there are no gods no
transcendence
only power to become a god is simply to
find that power
the lords found their powers amongst the
first flame and proclaimed themselves to
be gods
but as the flame fades the lords must
rely on illusions instead of power
until new fuel for the flame is found
as gwyn burns in his tomb gwyndolin and
frampt search desperately for someone to
replace him
to maintain the age of light a little
longer
solaire reminds me of the legend of
icarus
icarus is granted wings and uses them to
chase the sun
but he flies too close and falls to his
death
solaire has limitless ambition and
strives to obtain the sun as well
but he too runs the risk of flying too
close
it's hard to find the sun in lordran and
the world is already dark
perhaps solaire is looking for a new
light
there is a prophecy that comes from
salah's homeland in astora
a prophecy that sheds light on solaire's
quest
there is an old saying in my family thou
who art undead art chosen
and thine exodus from the undead asylum
maketh pilgrimage to the land of ancient
lords
when thou wringeth the bell of awakening
the fate
of the undead thou shalt know
to fulfill the prophecy you must be two
things
you must be undead and you must escape
the asylum
[Music]
oscar became undead and traveled to the
asylum to become a part of the prophecy
you carry out his legacy
but oscar was not the only one trying to
become a part of the prophecy
so they also escaped the asylum
the way i see it our fates appear to be
intertwined
both undead both imprisoned in the
asylum and now we both end up here
in a land brimming with hollows could
that really be mere chance
i hardly think so i became undead to
pursue this
solaire's quest meant so much that he
chose to become undead
to fit the prophecy so if you believe
that you are the chosen
undead then you and solaire are on the
same path and your meeting was not
chance
but fate you can choose to believe that
everything in your past led you here
but who was solaire before he became
undead and
met you gwyn
lord of sunlight had three children one
was named guinevere
who fled her father and anor londo as
the flame continued to fade
another was gwyndolin born of the moon
and raised as a daughter
master of illusion he maintains power in
anor londo through an illusion of his
sister
and a fake son the identity of the third
child is a mystery
all we know is that he was a god of war
but his foolishness led to the loss of
something invaluable
and he had his god status rescinded
statues were destroyed and there are
places where it is clear that there have
been obvious efforts to remove
all trace of him ever existing but in a
land far from anor londo
near an altar dedicated to sunlight
there is one statue
that remains it's the statue of a woman
holding a small child a child wielding a
sunlight straight sword
the same sword as solaire
[Music]
silay never talks of the past only of
the future
only of finding his son if he is the son
of gwyn
then he has fallen out of his father's
graces but who is gwen to take his
powers away
solaire would have lost his status and
nothing more
even though his equipment has no special
powers he travels through lordran with
little trouble
reaching anor londo demons ruins and
lost izalith before you
it is said that the god of war still
watches over his warriors
solaire crosses between worlds to help
you take down your foes
in the end it doesn't matter if solaire
is the son of gwyn
to the world he's simply a friendly man
who helps his comrades when they are in
need
he is a man who gave everything he had
to find something
despite looking like a fool
but after years of searching his hope
turns to despair
and his despair turns to madness
[Music]
ah
[Music]
finally i am
i have
my very own son i
am the son i've done it
i have yes i didn't
i did
my son it's setting
it's dark so
dark
solaire a man of indomitable will
loses his mind to a creature that looks
like the sun
and dies to your blade
or does he time in lordran
is convoluted and one undead may take a
different path
a path that lets the layer persist a
little longer
[Music]
a path that takes you both to the kill
of the first flame
where solaire can fight for his son
[Applause]
[Music]
with gwyn defeated solaire can light a
flame of his own
and return sunlight to the world
for the fire within solaire will burn
the brightest of all
[Music]
you